hey what's up guys my name is Jonah and
welcome to episode 4 of the second
season of game programming so last time
we took a look at sending packets and we
talked a little a little bit about how
servers work and how they send data and
and a little and also a little bit about
the protocols we have available to us as
far as network communication goes
primarily TCP and UDP of course so if
you missed that video there's will be an
annotation on my face or on the screen
that will take you back to episode 3
because you're gonna want to watch that
first before we get to this but today
we're going to talk about listening and
receiving data because I mean receiving
data is arguably a little bit more
complicated than sending data because
again with UDP you know sending data is
as simple as just saying I'm going to
package my daughter into like a byte
array and then just send it to specified
address and port right which is exactly
what we've done here in this sender
method right we've got this data that we
were sending we're sending all of it and
of course it's going to a specific
address and a port that's it we just hit
up soccer dots and if the socket is open
and if everything is working correctly
that will be sent okay as far as the
delivery goes of course we have no
guarantee that it actually gets to its
destination we have no guarantee that it
hasn't like changed or that it will get
there in order and there's just no
guarantees really at all and there's no
way for us right now from here to see if
it was delivered successfully right
don't think that we'll get some kind of
i/o exception if it doesn't reach its
destination no that's just for actually
sending it we're not going to receive
any kind of error messages if the do if
the receiving party doesn't receive it
because again we don't know if they
receive it or not we of course could get
the client or whoever we're sending this
to to transmit some kind of packet back
to us that actually says you know hey
hey I received data and then now of
course we'll be a little bit trending
more towards TCP and kind of a more I
guess it's like a safer protocol but we
will be developing like our own little
protocol here along with this series
that will kind of
all of our needs without having too much
extra kind of weight to it such as what
TCP would would have okay anyway so
listening right we have this listen
method and by listening of course I'm
just referring to the act of just
waiting really listening is like what
listening refers to in this in this
context is just waiting until we
actually get something right to
listening we listen until we receive
something of course that's why we have
this loop here now actually receiving
something is also quite easy in terms of
API wires right like data Gramm socket
if we take a look at what this socket
gives us and remember a packet is just
like it's like our our our mails right
it's like a letter or something or a
parcel
however our socket our diagram socket is
like our mailbox so of course if we want
to receive something or if we want to
check to receive mail right then then
our mailbox is what we need to go
through and of course we use the mailbox
here to actually send mail because this
is like you know in my awesome analogy
this is like us going to the mailbox and
putting a letter or a parcel into there
and here we also need to do kind of the
opposite where we go there and we check
to see if there's anything there ok so
if we take a look at diagram socket at
the diagram soccer class and we see what
we have here we have a few methods
I might just look at the eclipse outline
here I mean if we maximize this we can
probably see all the methods at once
here and of course we have our send
method it's actually probably not even
in this class yeah unfortunately this
isn't going to show us all the methods
that are in in like everything but um
let's see what we have here hmm
ok yep so we have send which we have
used and of course right next what we
also have receive so the receive method
will receive a Datagram prior from the
socket when this method returns the data
ramp of packets buffer is filled with
the data received ok cool so this
basically tells us that we get a
Datagram packet
there it is like us and will will have
to fade in a telegram packet and what
will happen here is the this diagram
packet will be filled with all of our
information so you can see we will
actually receive the information it does
some like security checking first that
you know just verifies everything's in
order and then it will eventually call
the receive method on on whatever
implementation I guess of the data I'm
soccerway using which could be any
number of classes I guess but yeah what
we need what we care about is any
exceptions that get thrown like we have
io exceptions like a timeout exception
port unreachable exception and of course
we have we also need to a K so it
doesn't return anything and it looks
like we need to provide the diagram
packet into which to place the incoming
data okay pretty simple so to get that
to work then this paragraph is also kind
of important because it tells us that
this method blocks until a diagram
package is received okay that means like
straight away that it will like wait
until it receives a packet so in here
they'll be like a while true loop you
can kind of see that here and that might
not be the right one it might be there
I'm not sure but oh man I just love how
this just allocates inside the while
loop as well Java anyway whatever so I'm
not gonna get into the details we have
this this this this wild true loop in
this method that blocks basically until
until it actually gets data okay and if
the message is just longer than packets
like the message is truncated that's
also important so we might not receive
the whole thing might be truncated and
maybe split up into two I'm not really
sure how that will work but the
important thing is we do need to provide
it with a packet so the parameter is
which is basically where the data will
go into so instead of returning a data
gram packet or something we actually
give it a diagram packet and then it
fills it with data and it will block
until it actually provides us with data
so to speak so what we need to do here
is actually
basically the first thing we need to do
is create a diagram packet were in like
which we can fill with information or
with data right
so we'll say data gram packet packet
equals new data gram packet now when we
make a packet that we don't want to send
anywhere we don't need to use the
constructor that has the einer address
in the port or anything like that we
just need the one that has the buffer
and the length okay so we should have
some kind of buffer in which we can
actually put our data into now what we
could do right if we were kind of just
doing this in a simple way is we could
simply kind of create our data right we
might have like some kind of packet size
that we provide this with so we might
have like some default you know like max
packet size or I don't know we might
have something like a constant up here
what we have a private final and you
know max packet size may be 1,024 bytes
right so one kilobyte is our maximum
packet size for example doesn't have to
be that and then of course we can just
do something like that okay now that's a
little bit wasteful we don't necessarily
want to do that the reason is that every
time we receive a diagram packet or any
anytime we receive some kind of data
which again when our server starts
running will be like every like
millisecond probably if not more than
that right I mean we're gonna be
receiving data all the time I mean if
you if you take a look at maybe like a
client sending 10 to 20 updates per
second and we have like you know a
hundred clients or something all
connected at once and in peak like at
peak performance I guess we might be
receiving somewhere in the realm of like
2000 or so packets per second right
which is a lot and so we don't want to
be and so every time that happens we
will be allocating and creating a new
byte array right so the server is going
to be constantly allocating the
allocating memory
now if Java is at all smart and I don't
know that it is right I mean I have no
experience really kind of going down and
seeing what like I've never looked at
Javas byte code or whatever
the producers and I don't even know if
there's an easy way to do that without
actually like examining maybe the class
files or not even the class files but
just I don't know maybe there's a
compiler option to output like the
equivalent of assembly from what Java's
bytecode will actually become to take a
look at what it will do but I mean I you
know if Java was smart of course it
would see that we're allocating this
byte data and deallocating it like I
mean it's not getting D allocated here
because we're not really deleting it but
ideally like it would only be used in
this scope and maybe like Java's
compiler could do an optimization where
it reuses this data so it allocates and
of course it sees that we only use it
for this scope and thus maybe it can
optimize that and then say that ok I'm
only going to allocate this basically
once and then I want to reuse that same
block of memory every time it could do
that
I mean C++ will actually perform that
optimization for you but I again I don't
know if Java will so this is a simple
way to do it it's gonna look good like
it makes sense however we're gonna go a
little bit further and we're just gonna
put us out at out here in fact I'm gonna
go further again and say we're going to
make a private final static that doesn't
have to be static but a private final it
doesn't have to be final either
I just just really just a just a private
byte and I'll pull this something like
receive received dot up a buffer and
we'll do something like not an hour max
packet size times 10 all right so the
maybe we can use this 10 times or
something like that and and we'll see
kind of how that comes into play but the
idea is that we allocate this once right
for each server object essentially and
then we can continually reuse that that
that buffer right so we can have
something like receive data buffer and
then the length can be you know max
packet size okay so we're not you can
see that we're not using the whole thing
right now we're using the first block of
the
10 in this case 10 kilobytes that we
have in this buffer but what we're
essentially doing is we're just we're
going to be filling that first kind of
10% of it with this packet up to 10% of
it with this packet right and we're
certainly not doing any kind of dynamic
allocation or even or over again inside
this loop anymore so that's good we're
reusing that memory that we've already
pre allocated so it's already better
than what we had before so what we'll do
finally is now that we have a packet we
can actually receive data so we'll say
socket dot receive packet now this will
of course throw a bunch of exceptions we
could handle absolutely all of them I
mean we know that it throws more than
i/o exception that's another thing
that's why reading the documentation is
a good idea you know if we look at
eclipses options for this I mean it only
actually offers to handle an i/o
exception for us I mean other IDs like
IntelliJ or something might do something
differently but in this case you can see
we only get IO exception however we know
from reading the docs that this actually
throws one of four exceptions okay so if
we wanted to be a bit more particular
about how we handle things and a bit
more so I guess safe then we might you
know want to additionally be like oh
okay
you know I want to also monitor a socket
timeout exception right so we might also
want to cache you know a sock a timeout
exception or something like this okay
and then we could I don't know for the
satirize we probably have to actually
switch these yeah like we could do
something like that okay and in this
case we're handling both exceptions I
don't really care about that we'll just
catch an i/o exception I'm pretty sure
well the only reason that works as well
is because something like a socket you
can see that a socket timeout exception
extends an interrupted i/o exception
which extends an i/o exception so a
socket timeout exception is an IO
exception which is why I kind of if we
handle this it is gonna catch all of
them it's just that we you know you can
see here we don't really know her we
could do something like he instances of
soccer timeout exception and that would
work but we don't want to do that
of course we could just handle the other
exception that we get all right cool so
that's the idea of how that's gonna work
it's pretty simple that's really all we
kind of need to do as far as that goes
if we do receive the data at this point
we now have a pack
that we can play around with in terms of
like we now have a packet that contains
all of our data that we've drous Eve
okay as long as it's below max packet
size and we'll talk about handling
larger packets when we get when we get
there but we have this socket received
thing which of course if that like that
will block right that will continually
what will happen will this while loop
right that's why we started it on a new
on a different thread by the way because
socket I receive as the documentation
says will block meaning that this will
actually like our this thread will be
basically paused on this line not really
paused because of course internally
there is a while true loop that is
running inside this method but you know
if we just look at this class it'll be
basically paused on here until it
actually receives data as soon as it
receives data provided and throw an
exception we will end up over here so
that's where our process function comes
in we're going to process the packet
that we just received
now the packet that we receive an attack
and like the way that we decided process
it of course will be primarily using our
series ation format so you know some
things we could do for example would be
I don't even remember how this is laid
out really it's been a while since I
looked at this database I guess is what
I want yeah you can see we have a header
of our CD B so something that might be
nice to look at is something like we
might want to assert for example this is
this would be if we're using if our CD B
so you might even want to check to see
if it is an RCD b packet and and the way
we can do that actually i was going to
do an assert but actually now that we
have these two options what we might
want to do is something as simple as if
new string now the by it will be package
dot get data okay i'm actually going to
do that I assume we can specify length
yes again
so offset zero length four so we get the
fourth first four characters out of
there assuming the divorce we have
single byte characters which we should I
believe you to f8
but anyway or asked you or something if
we we can basically just see if that if
the first kind of four bytes here is
actually equal to rc DB right and if it
is then obviously we are an RC DB object
because we know that that's how our our
database begins and and if that does
happen then again remember deserializing
that is going to be as simple as using
our thing it's just going to be as
simple as saying I'll see now have I not
linked it maybe not okay no all right so
anyway again as I said one of those each
episode is is mandatory will have will
have will make sure that rain server
actually does have will add will go to
the build path so right click properties
and then go to the build path and then
will in the problem that under the
projects tab will just make sure that
rain cloud civilization is actually
selected as a required project for the
build path and that'll make sure of
course that we can use stuff like an RC
database so if we do ask the database
dot deserialize we can of course and of
course this is like okay we can't of
course just do that right and then
suddenly what we have is a diabase yeah
and that that's as simple as that is
really however what we can do then is
say that you know if that isn't the case
and then we can process the database
however we like we might even have
another process private void process we
might even have another process function
here that actually takes in a database
and then presence is that right and then
we can actually you know for me
we could start by doing something like
printing out a name or we could do
anything right cuz we have an RC
database now and garen client database
so that's one thing we could do of
course I you know I mean I checked to
see if we have this header like this you
don't have to make a new string or
anything to check that there are a
billion ways you could check that I
could have also equally written
something like if you know I don't even
know how to do like a mem compare and
Java it's probably system dot I just
don't even know man I mean like mem
copies like a right copy but like I just
don't even know how to compare to huh
any way you could just compare the by
it's what I'm saying I can't believe
like I'm really quite terrible at Java
googling this right now because I just
want to know how to do that arrays dot
equals okay arrays dot equals see that's
not I don't actually want to do that
though because I also want to specify
size so if there was an arrays dot
equals overload what you could do is
something like data you know a new byte
ah C D B and then just do something like
so that and then like specify length of
four bytes
okay and then of course if you did
something like that then that would be
kind of your comparison as well and of
course instead of allocating is here or
whatever you could do that externally
and just have that like as a static
piece of memory to compare against and
that would be fine as well right I've
just written it this particular way for
no apparent reason but we are of course
just creating a string out of the first
four characters of although we're
creating a string out of the first four
bytes of the packet that we received
okay cool so that being said and I might
I might implement this a little bit
differently later on but that is the way
that we can do that and then of course
if it's not if it doesn't equal RCTV
means it's not a database so in this
case you know I mean we ideally do want
to be sending our CD B's however we
don't need to do that for stuff like
maybe the establishing connection I mean
you could however you might want to do
something like not do that right so in
that case you could do something like
you know if you like we could have an
error like a little micro format that we
use just for you know establishing
connection or sending timeout packets or
you know pings and stuff like that right
so we could just do something like for
example if a packet was laid out so the
first byte was like the type ii by it
was like the message or something like
that then we could of course just do
something like if data or you know
switch data 0 right so we're checking
the first byte of the packet and then we
could do something like okay well it
does wander and it's a you know it's a
connection packet so we'll handle the
connection right and we can just do
something as simple as that just to
you know verify kind of what type it is
and then act appropriately so you know
that might be a connection packet or
something you know - might be like a
like a ping kind of timeout packet thing
like there could be a bunch of other
stuff you know three could be like a
login attempts like there's just you
know we could have like one of these for
everything of course we could also
package it in a database it's just
something for some cases like we might
not want to do that I still recommend
packaging it in a database the reason is
that this isn't particularly the RC
database thing that we've created has
kind of been quote-unquote optimized for
the network like I've written it with a
network stuff in mind which means that
it's not particularly heavyweight and of
course it does mean that we can just for
example get like the root object or
something from the database I think we
just how do we actually do that
so if like find object there should be a
way to just return the first object
which we will like we will end up
extending the rain cloud server ization
libraries API as if it has to be
required but you know we might have like
a route object so we can find the object
and then we can of course you know find
the field of you know username or
something and we can get the string out
of that or that'll actually be a string
it's sort of the field right yeah don't
get named and we've got sighs I'm going
to get string for example so that could
be like for example our username right
so we can just do that really and you
can see the WIDA like from this side we
don't require anything like we don't
have to you know actually go through the
bytes we don't have to like you know do
some weird thing where we like end up
making a new string from that data like
from that byte array with some like
weird offset and like some weird you
know length that we might have read from
somewhere like else or whatever like it
it gets really complicated and very
error-prone if we start doing that which
is why there's having this API having
this database that we know is in a
certain format and we've already written
all the code to handle that you know
having a standard basically is going to
make sure that we don't have those bugs
so yes that is the way that the cookie
crumbles I don't know why I'm keep
saying that and I'd like to come my son
off
but that's basically all I wanted to say
today that's how we receive packets by
using sohcahtoa receive and then
basically our job is to process packets
so we now have a full server that is
capable about sending and receiving
packets if we go back to our rain server
and we run it for example we shouldn't
get any errors if we hit pause so I'll
switch to the debug perspective real
quick and I'll hit the pause button up
here you can see that we have a few
threads running primarily we have thread
0 ok so we didn't name our thread let's
name our thread so what we'll do is in
this lesson thread I think I believe
after this yes so we can provide a name
for it so I'll call this rain I'll call
this what is this do we have a name for
our thread no I didn't rain cloud server
listen thread or something like that
right and that means that if we run this
and again if I hit pause you can see you
can see we have this a thread that's
called rain cloud server listen through
it right so we know exactly what this is
and we can see what is doing like it's
essentially in this implementation or
whatever it's actually I don't know why
doesn't jump to line not available okay
whatever but you can see that it's
coming from our server dot listen thing
and it's being blocked on that soccer
dot received thing until actually
receive something so yeah so we can see
how that's running and everything is
basically set up and it's just listening
for some data so next time we're going
to actually switch over to the client
side to rein in episode 5 and we're
going to basically write some code that
is capable of sending so we have a
server and a we're gonna create a client
and a clients gonna be much like a
server you'll see with a few kind of
features missing essentially like it's
still gonna have a listen and a Santa
method it's just not gonna have you know
the way that it sets up the sockets and
stuff is gonna be a little bit different
although since this is UDP it will still
kind of be the same almost like the own
like in terms of communication you know
a client a servant doesn't really differ
too much in terms of the API that it
uses because you know both a client and
a server still needs to send and receive
data it's just the
well the thing that will differ is what
data it sends what data it receives and
what it does the data it receives right
so how it processes how it processes the
data okay cool well that's the end of
this video I hope you guys enjoyed it if
you did please hit the like button below
if you want to support the series and
get access to the source code then you
can go to patreon.com/scishow Cherno
pledge five dollars or more per month
and you will get access to this page
which is a private github repository
which contains every single episode of
the game programming series in a
convenient format which you can diff
against the previous things for example
I mean this is a great example as we
added a bunch of files but episode 3 and
4 will be pushed as separate commits in
a minute I'm just a to literally do that
and of course you also get access to
develop to development branches such as
multiplayer which already has a lot of
this code written so yes so you can see
that I've in here I've done stuff like
multiplayer prototyping and you know
I've already set up like a client-server
communication so if you want to get a
jump on the episodes and stuff like that
then just feel free to just to support
the series on patreon and also if you
want to talk about this a really good
place to do that is on my slack channel
so if you go to slack the channel
comment your email address here you'll
get an invite to my slack team and
there's a channel there called game
programming which is dedicated to
talking about this series so if you want
to discuss your thoughts with someone in
like an instant messenger kind of
real-time format rather than just
comments or forums then this is the
place to go if you want to talk about it
alright cool well anyway I'll see you
guys next week leave your thoughts in
the comments below if you agree or
disagree with anything I said in this
episode or you want me to cover
something in greater detail and I will
see you guys next time goodbye